hallo
gern mit uns die berufe auf deutsch
das ist ein gerichtsgebäude
das ist tina sie arbeitet als anwältin
china vertritt klienten vor gericht der
anwalt die anwältin
der anwalt die anwältin
das ist eine arztpraxis
das ist mag
mag arbeitet
er untersucht patienten
der arzt die ärztin
der arzt die ärztin das ist eine
tierarztpraxis
das ist rossi jose arbeitet als tierarzt
er kümmert sich um die tiere
der tierarzt die tierärztin
das ist ein restaurant das ist carlo
carlo ist kellner
er serviert das essen der kellner die
kellnerin der kellner die kellnerin
das ist ein kleiderladen das ist laura
sie arbeitet als verkäuferin
sie hilft bei der kleiderauswahl der
verkäufer die verkäuferin
der verkäufer die verkäuferin
das ist eine maschinen werkstatt das
sind max und jenny sie arbeiten als
maschinenbauingenieure sie entwerfen und
testen autos
der maschinenbauingenieur die
maschinenbau ingenieurin der
maschinenbauingenieur die maschinenbau
ingenieurin
das ist ein labor das sind emma und
harold sie arbeiten als wissenschaftler
sie erfinden dinge die unser leben
einfacher machen
der wissenschaftler die
wissenschaftlerin
das ist eine apotheke das ist manuel er
arbeitet als apotheker manuel hilft den
kunden und kundinnen mit ihren
medikamenten
der apotheker die apothekerin
das ist ein krankenhaus das ist gregorio
er arbeitet als krankenpfleger gregorio
kümmert sich um die patienten
der krankenpfleger die krankenpflegerin
das ist eine bank das ist sabine sie
arbeitet als bankangestellte sie berät
die bankkunden und bank kundinnen
der bankangestellte die bankangestellte
das ist eine firma das ist leer
sie arbeitet als sekretärin
sie empfängt die kunden und organisiert
den terminplan ihres chefs
der sekretär die sekretärin der sekretär
die sekretärin
das ist ein büro das ist david er
arbeitet als kameramann david macht
videos für die firmen
der kameramann die kamerafrau der
kameramann die kamerafrau das ist
juliane sie arbeitet als personalchefin
sie interviewt und wählt die arbeiter
aus
der personalchef die personalchefin der
personalchef die personalchefin
wir sind in einem haus das in flammen
steht
das sind matthäus und sandra matthäus
ist feuerwehrmann und sandra ist
feuerwehrfrau sie retten und helfen
menschen aus dem feuer
der feuerwehrmann die feuerwehrfrau der
feuerwehrmann die feuerwehrfrau das ist
eine kunstgalerie das ist adrian er
arbeitet als künstler
er malt sehr schöne bilder
der künstler die künstlerin der künstler
die künstlerin
das ist eine küche
das sind andrea martin und peter sie
arbeiten als kirche
sie machen leckere gerichte
der koch die köchin
der koch die kirchen
das ist ein supermarkt das ist sophia
sofia arbeitet als kassiererin
sie arbeitet in einem supermarkt der
kassierer die kassiererin
der kassierer die kassiererin
[Musik]
wir sind am tatort das sind antonio und
stefanie
sie arbeiten als polizisten sie fangen
die verbrecher
der polizist die polizistin
das ist eine fabrik das sind manolo und
korn
sie arbeiten als architektin
sie entwerfen gebäude der architekt die
architektin
der architekt die architektin
wir sind auf der straße das ist marco er
arbeitet als postbote er stellt die post
pakete zu der postbote die postbotin der
postbote die postbotin das ist ein
garten das ist olivia olivia arbeitet
als gärtnerin
sie kümmert sich um die pflanzen der
gärtner die gärtnerin der gärtner die
gärtnerin
das ist ein büro das ist markus markus
ist technischer direktor
er plant strategien für den club der die
hre
die direktorin der direktor
die direktorin das ist eine werbeagentur
das ist bastian
er arbeitet als grafiker
er entwirft websites für unternehmen
der grafiker die grafikerin der grafiker
die grafikerin wir sind auf einer
abschlussfeier
das ist boris
er aber
als fotograf
er fotografiert zu besonderen anlässen
der fotograf die fotografen
das ist eine schule das ist angela sie
arbeitet als lehrerin
sie unterrichtet deutsch in der schule
der lehrer die lehrerin der lehrer die
lehrerin
wir sind in einem bus das ist clemens er
arbeitet als busfahrer er transportiert
menschen von einem ort zum anderen
der busfahrer die busfahrerin
das ist ein flughafen das ist fabian er
arbeitet als pilot er fliegt ein
flugzeug und reist in verschiedene
länder
der pilot die pilotin
das ist ein konzert
das ist franz franz ist sänger er singt
lieder der sänger designerin
der sänger die sängerin
wir sind im fernsehstudio das ist
gabriela
sie arbeitet als journalistin
sie moderiert die nachrichten der welt
der journalist die journalisten
der journalist die journalistin was ist
dein beruf als was arbeitest
schreibt ein beruf in die kommentare
mein beruf ist
ich arbeite als möchtest du gratis
online deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal